retour au cinéma maintenant avec la nuit
des césars 84 la soirée retransmise par
antenne 2 commence dans un peu plus de
dix minutes
il est temps de retrouver france roche
qui a réuni quelques unes des
personnalités les plus marquantes de
cette nuit ce soir quatre théâtres
commenceront leurs représentations avec
une heure de retard en effet deux de ces
théâtres permettront à suzanne flon et à
jacques villeret devenir peut-être
rendre leurs prix et deux autres
permettront à marcello mastroianni à
bernard giraudeau et à claude rich de
venir remettre ses prix alors j'ai opté
pour à claude berri qui est un des
favoris puisque vous avez 11 nominations
contraires aux français quelle
impression à ton quand on a onze
nominations avec en a presque son prix
il ya douze nominations
non non écouter des fois il vaut mieux
pas être favori être à l'arrivée on
verra j'attends merci il y aura aussi
jack nicholson charles bronson roman
polanski et bien sûr le président de nec
élite à qui je vais demander s'il sera
un président en dansant où un président
parlant en tout cas tout le monde est
dans les voitures et vous allez les voir
arriver à l' empire
voilà isabelle adjani qui a rompu son
habitude de ne pas sortir le soir et
voici monica vitti qui elle aussi
remettra des prix sur la scène
et michel serrault qui arrive avec les
cheveux complètement rasé qui est en
train de dire que s'il avait su il
aurait même des cheveux qu'il aurait
misé ses cheveux de soirée
eh bien nous allons nous retrouver dans
une dizaine ou une douzaine de minutes à
l' empire et vous saurez tout sur les
huitièmes césar de la neige